[Music]
okay Topher there is plain a real life
character and then there's plain David
Duke when you're taking him on I mean
what is that much it's not a fictional
bad guy it's a real bad guy we're still
feeling the consequences of things that
he's done and things he's doing so I I
just did as much research as I could and
I'm talking like the most depressing
month of my life my wife will tell you
it was like a terrible month to be
around then I was rehearsing lines once
we had the baby and she was like hey can
you cool it on the hate speech a little
bit like maybe do that in your office
yeah it's coming up on the twentieth
anniversary of that seven D show can you
believe that no yeah someone asked me
today if I would have thought twenty
years ago I started because that also
took place in the 70s if I'd be playing
a white supremacist stephanie's and the
answer is no I did not know that age of
reboots could there be one with you guys
I I I always say I would love I mean
absolutely love to do it I doubt it only
because that cast went on to have so
much success I mean if they're down I'm
down cuz I love those guys
[Music]